[Applause]
nerdcon in boston was so amazing that i
barely took any video so I'm just gonna
talk over this footage of Hank green and
the perfect strangers rocking out two
songs about science I want to try to say
now what I struggled to say during the
nerdcon closing ceremonies so I was
thinking about Esther a lot this weekend
Esther Earl was a nerdfighter who with
her friends helped run the
behind-the-scenes of the project for
awesome and she died of cancer in 2010
when she was 16 Esther and I met in
Boston and her make-a-wish brought some
of her nerdfighter friends and I to
Boston and now here we were again
dancing and singing along to songs
Esther loved on Saturday I visited her
grave with her parents and one of her
sisters a lot of nerdfighters have
visited over the years actually and left
artwork and keychains and this star
won't go out bracelets and I was
thinking about how Esther met her
nerdfighter friends in the comments of
our old blog TV live shows like after
the show's ended they would stay in the
chat room and talk to each other their
friendship basically happened in a space
that we created and then vacated hank
when i look back at the last 10 years of
blogg brothers i don't really think
about the videos malcolm gladwell
famously said that it takes 10,000 hours
of practice to become expert at
something but even after far more than
10,000 hours I'm still not really good
at making YouTube videos I mean I can
manage a jump cut but that's about it so
yeah I don't really think about the
videos I think about people making stuff
together and using that stuff to connect
with each other I think about an
Amsterdam nerdfighter gathering in 2008
where two people met who would later get
married I think about the project for
awesome and scavenger hunts and about
how blog brothers is one of the very few
channels on YouTube where the comments
are often better than the videos
ultimately fandoms are made interesting
not by the content but by the people who
choose to build communities around the
content like Harry Potter is an
excellent book series but what makes it
special is finally not JK Rowling but
readers choosing to respond deeply and
enthusiastically and without
embarrassment or apology by dressing up
or writing and reading fanfiction or
singing that the weapon we have is love
Hank we've been incredibly fortunate
over the last decade that so many
awesome people have chosen to invest
themselves in nerdfighteria sometimes I
feel guilty about it because I've
benefited so disproportionately from
something I only had a small part in
creating each Tuesday I try to repay a
little bit of that debt but it only
seems to grow which brings me back to
Esther and her gray
I kept wondering how you thank someone
who is gone how you repay them for the
deep lasting gifts that their love and
friendship brought you when you can no
longer do anything for them she isn't
here when I've lost people I care about
that part never stops feeling new they
aren't here it cracks me open each time
I think it she died as a past tense
problem she isn't here is a present
tense problem but you are here whoever
you are however you came upon this video
you are here and we're lucky to have you
here and grateful and while we are here
together let's try to be kind and to
create spaces where cool stuff can
happen so nerdfighters thank you for
your comments and your art and your
writing and your collaborations and all
the awesome you have brought into the
world in the last 10 years Hank I will
see you on Friday